welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host the death knight of back with
you weekly update on the Batman every
week same bat-time same bat-channel and
we do a big breakdown on all of the
updates on the upcoming film and this
week there's a lot to unpack the movie
officially started it's principal
photography this week and we've learned
a lot from its cast list including who
the villains will be and more throughout
this video we're gonna be breaking it
all down and giving our thoughts on what
it means there may be some spoilers here
so if you don't want to know anything
about the film then I highly suggest
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of the Batman 2021 okay so
this week we've had no updates on the
Batsuit or Batmobile however there has
been a lot of fake news flying about in
regards to the car from a number of
different sources the first one looked
like a nice muscle car that was in line
with the descriptions that we got on the
vehicle however this is actually from
movie world Australia so yeah don't let
the Joker clickbait you the second that
was floating around and made it look
like the car had jet engines attached to
it well bear this was also from Warner
Brothers to buy there's a ton of fake
stuff floating about in regards to the
movie and personally I don't think that
we'll see the Batmobile or bat suit
until Matt Reeves wants us to even the
world's greatest detective will have
trouble leaking it as these things are
in high-security vaults locked in the
Batcave
so yeah next time you think the
Batmobile has been posted just go in
with some skepticism because there's so
much of this kind of thing popping up
every day anyway the week's started off
with Matt Reeves officially announcing
that filming had begun we did believe
that it started in London a couple of
weeks ago but now we know that this was
mainly for location scouting as well as
the cast getting their costumes fit
occasionally they do photoshoots during
this time so things can be used in
marketing and this is probably what
happened then the air Pattinson could
still show up on a motorbike at some
point as well as the Gotham action news
fans and so on the clapperboard states
that the film will be shot in two by 39
by one which is widescreen to you and me
and that it will be 24 frames per second
this is standard across the board and
it's a very very bold choice for a movie
so yeah this won't be like Gemini man
which was shot at a headache-inducing a
hundred and twenty frames per second the
logo itself actually reminds me a lot of
the Batman Beyond one and I love the red
lettering whether this is used as the
final font for the film we don't know
yet as sometimes Studios do use it and
sometimes they don't the logos often get
revised so though a lot of people are
saying this is the way that the film
will be marketed I wouldn't take it to
be just yet remember remember what I
told you about the Joker guys an
interesting thing you may notice from
the image is that the clapperboard is
against a leather-bound chair and this
will likely be one that Bruce sits and
broods in this could be a callback to
the Caped Crusader's origin story in
which the characters sat before he was
greeted by the bat that would inspire
him to become the Batman as we know this
is the first film in a new trilogy so it
does make sense that they would pull
from the iconography of the first comic
books a chair like this also appeared in
Batman Returns at the start of the movie
when Bruce was sitting about staring
into space waiting for that moment that
a notification pops up to tell them
there's more Batman news well they were
very sad life judging by the style of it
and the context it is likely that this
piece of furniture will come directly
from Wayne Manor personally I love the
look and I'm glad that they're going
with this kind of aesthetic Reeves also
took to Twitter this morning to confirm
which Batman villains would be appearing
in the movie it's been long thought that
they would be the Riddler penguin and
Catwoman and no matter how many times we
got this covered tells you there's gonna
be eight villains in it the image that
was posted today confirms that those are
the ones we'll be getting
though we haven't seen their costumes
yet this is a nice little callback to
the 1966 version of The Dark Knight
backing this up is also an official cast
list the outlines who everyone will be
playing and once more it lists these
three where rumors and a lot of articles
published recently that said Harvey Dent
would be in the film
and that this could tease two-face but
going off this official cast list from
Warner Brothers it doesn't look like
he'll be in the movie these cast lists
can always be amended so don't count the
character out just yet but they may be
serving him
a sequel similar to how the dog night
did well it does confirm though is that
Annie circus will indeed be playing
Bruce Wayne's Butler the infamous Alfred
circus has long been thought of as
playing the part and he's had a very
close relationship with Matt Reeves
since they worked together on the Planet
of the Apes trilogy this is great news
and I'm so glad that we finally got
someone who I think is a pretty
underrated actor playing the Dark
Knight's number two not that kind of
number two he's not Gwon oh man hey you
haven't that bad fans that's a that's a
callback to Circus is known
predominantly for his motion capture
work but I think he will do really well
in the role and I can't wait to see him
picking up glasses after Bruce Wayne in
the movie in addition to this we now
know that Peter Sarsgaard will be
playing Gotham District Attorney and
Gail Coulson so Harvey Dent is not the
DA of Gotham and he may end up being
elected at some point in his movie or
the next depending on if he's added to
the cast list or not now you may have
noticed from the cast list there is
quite a lot of policemen and members of
the law being added to the lineup and
this actually could paint out the state
that Gotham is in before Batman yay one
Gotham was always thought of as a great
place that though it had crime wasn't
the cesspool that we now know Frank
Miller completely reinvented this and in
an interview he stated that he never
understood why Batman was needed when
Gotham was so good so in his seminal
graphic novel year one he completely
flipped Gotham on its head and made it a
center for corruption and deceit and
thus this underworld required someone to
step in and be the Batman in order to
stop it this aesthetic has remained ever
since and I definitely think with all
the law enforcement officers that been
cast in the film that we'll be seeing
something similar here I love watching
the corrupt side of Gotham and my
favorite time in Batman comics was when
the Caped Crusader was fighting the
police just as much as he was the
criminals hopefully they go ahead with
it as I'd absolutely love to see that in
the movie and it always makes for an
interesting way to portray the character
we also have some tidbits on how the
characters from the cast list could end
up looking which I'll get into in just a
bit
before we get into the rest of the video
though I just wanna let you know we're
giving away a free copy of dr. sleep to
one random subscriber all you have to do
to be one with the chance of winning is
like the video subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the updates
in the comment section below the winners
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
February and the set will be shipped out
from the interval gets the prize it's
the best of luck that everyone who takes
part okay so we have some news in
regards to who will be doing the makeup
on the project that is Naomi done not
only did she work on Skyfall but she
also recently did the makeup for
overlord
so as the tweet on-screen rightly says
if they do end up using Too Faced and
the character is in good hands this also
brings up the prospect of penguins nose
there's been a lot of back-and-forth
over whether Farrell would end up
donning a prosthetic or not
however with dawn on the project it
seems likely that will be done in one
Don always pushes the bow out as much as
possible and if we were to hazard a
guess we would say that the character
will indeed be appearing with one that
would make Pinocchio jealous it's the
type who knows your granddad would grab
and say I've got your nose and you'd go
granddad keep it the last story in
regards to the film is about Robert
Pattinson comments that he made last
year in which he said Batman wasn't a
superhero naturally most people didn't
really care but this sent some corners
of the internet into an angered frenzy
the actor got a lot of backlash for at
the time and yet people like this guy
shouldn't be Batman go back to Twilight
Pattinson has since come out this
morning and retracted what he said and
when discussing whether the character
was a superhero or not he stated the
following I wasn't educated about the
subject people got very angry about it
it's bizarre I still can't understand
the argument okay he's a superhero I'm
sorry
the next headline Pattinson retracts
Batman is in fact superhero he takes it
back you bloody bet you that'll be the
next headline person I'll never let you
forget this never anyway that's all of
the news it's pretty good that we now
have a full cast list and some ideas on
how the characters could look everything
is falling together and though I do
think the announcements over the neck
couple of weeks will be official ones
instead of set leaks there's still a lot
to look forward to thanks for checking
the video out I'll see you next week
same bat-time same bat-channel or
whenever I feel like doing a video now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the updates and if you're excited for
the film comment below and let me know
and if you enjoy this video then please
give it a thumbs up and if you missed
last week's entry then make sure you
check it out after this we go over the
Batsuit and Batmobile descriptions and
talk Colin Farrell's penguin so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below you get access to content early
and can also suggest video topics and
breakdowns we massively appreciate it
and it goes a long way to helping videos
like this get made you want to come chat
to us after the show either follow us a
definition whitey or click the discord
link in the description below those are
the best ways to keep up to date with
heavy spoilers so hopefully we see over
there very soon this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]